it's guys my name is the Jonah welcome
back to my game engine series so last
time we continued on with the dock space
we talked about frame buffers and all
that stuff definitely check out that
video if you haven't already and today I
thought it would have a nice fairly
quick hopefully chill episode in which
we take a look at what it takes to
actually set up a new project in hazel
now this is something that when I say
that I specifically I'm just talking
about like development wise within
Visual Studio so this isn't like how to
make a new game or new app using hazel
because obviously once we have like a
whole tool chain and a set of tools for
hazel it will be done kind of it there
I'm just talking about more or less like
we have this sandbox project now if we
want to kind of programmatically in a
C++ fashion add a new project to Hazel
that uses hazel such as a level editor
which is what we're going to be doing
here today how would we do that because
a few few people have actually asked me
what that would look like but also it's
going to be really important for us
because at the moment we're kind of
building our editor within sandbox and
that's not something that we want to
continue doing it's probably a good
thing to move that out of there as fast
as possible and leave sandbox being our
kind of test runtime environment so if
we pop over to visual studio let's start
off with first of all talking about what
we want to do so you can see in the
solution Explorer we've got a bunch of
dependencies we've got hazel we've got
sandbox so what I want to do is create
something else called the hazel editor
now in the development branch is called
hazel nut I don't know if I am 100% sold
on that name I think it might be better
to kind of keep it more or less simple
maybe just call it hazel editor if you
guys have any suggestions then um leave
a comment below as to if you like the
name hazel not if you think hazel editor
is better
normally in Visual Studio we just go
right click add new project and set all
that stuff up but we can actually do it
a different way in fact we should do it
a different way when working with hazel
and that is through premake so if we
open up the pre make file there's this
primary five dollar at the root of the
repository I'll just drag this
individual studio just to open it in the
text editor you can use any text editor
obviously since I've got Visual Studio
open I'm just going to use that you can
see that we've got our hazel project and
over here we have else
and box projects now the sandbox project
is basically what we want to use as like
a starting template because haze because
sandbox is a console app that obviously
links to hazel so if we look at what its
kind of made up of we've got the kind of
target directory an object directory it
is like intermediate directories that
pretty much the same as they are in
hazel then we've got a list of files
which is just again you can save the
fairly generic is just project name and
then slash source so if we know that
hazel not or I keep saying hazel not
hazel editor is going to use this kind
of same pattern here what we have like
you know hazel editor which is the
product name and then slash source and
then in there all of our source files
exist then you can use this obviously
otherwise your life if you don't have a
source directory you can get rid of it
and you guys get the drill include
directories these are all kind of things
that need to be in an in a hazel app at
the moment so basically vendor we use
hazel sauce we use that we can actually
use like the hazel include directories
and stuff like that and then hazel
vendor SPG log include as well because
like speed log is something that
obviously you know we want to be able to
also use inside applications that use
hazel not just in Hazel's core itself
and therefore it needs to be exposed it
just links hazel because hazel actually
links everything else so that's kind of
easy and then we have a few different
things here primarily for Windows we
just use system version latest this will
have a few different like platform
specific things as well as configuration
specific things but for now it's fairly
fairly standard so to make this happen
let's copy and paste sandbox one other
thing you could do technically is also
move this into its own kind of pre
mcclure file and then you can actually
include it now there's as I think it
include is it external or something like
that yep so something called include
external actually will essentially
include the script but I think that this
you can include script which might
contain one or more project or rule
definite
and all such containers will be marked
as external and simply referenced but
not regenerated because every time you
included it actually tends to regenerate
a project but if you just do include
external instead of include it's not
actually going to run the Lua script is
just gonna include the project so this
is something that you can do because
like in some situations you might want
to include things multiple times because
you have multiple solutions that you're
potentially generating but you don't
want to regenerate the entire project
again and again and again because that's
not going to be useful at all so that's
something that you can do as well we're
not gonna bother with that here I'll
just because this is like to me this is
still call hazel in fact if anything Sam
both should be standalone but the hazel
editor should probably be inside the
hazel solution as well so anyway
scrolling down here - so this is the
second sandbox and that's the first
sandbox we're just gonna call this hazel
- editor and location is going to be
hazel - editor which means that that's
the folder that we have it's going to be
a console app C++ it was 417 a static
runtime on the total directory and
object directory stays the same the
files we're gonna use the same structure
here this stays the same links hazel
everything's the same literally the only
thing we've changed is the actual name
and that's it
so now if we run pre-make not sure
anything will happen because we don't
actually have that directory set up but
if we try to make this happen
okay no it does everything it creates
the directory for us and it's made of
ECX project for us which is great so
inside here I want to make a source
directory and then I want to put all of
my sauce pertinent to this so again as a
starting point I'm going to go back here
to sandbox and I'm going to grab what I
want from sandbox so at the moment I
mean we're basically using the entirety
of sandbox we're in an example layer but
let's take sandbox app and sandbox 2d so
I'll copy that and I'll paste it over
here and instead of sandbox app I'll
pull this hazal editor app that's kind
of like our application I guess and then
we'll just have editor layer and that'll
be our kind of default layer for the
hazel editor so now if I go back here to
scripts and regenerate the project go
back to visual studio hit reload you'll
see that I should have a hazel editor
over here and we can make like a folder
called tools or something like that
if you look at the premake file which is
actually here you'll see that we have
this dependencies folder it's like a
solution folder or a filter and the way
that that's achieved is just by having a
group here so we have like a group
dependencies and then under the under
that we have certain projects and you
can see actually the include external
include thing is happening here because
it's not included more than once we're
just using include because you have to
run include the first time but then
include external the second time I think
I have an OpenGL related video that
actually talks a little bit more about
that so if you're interested in having
pre make files and organizing your kind
of I guess solution or project better by
having external premake files that you'd
then include here so that it's not all
cluttered then I'll have the video
linked up there which talks a little bit
more about how you can organize yourself
with pre make a bit better and again
that's just not a decision I'm making
right now to have this all external I'm
just gonna keep it here for now and if
this gets huge then I will kind of
refactor it and move it out okay but
that's really all we need from pre Meg
if we go over here the other thing we
could do by the way while I'm here is
just the start project we could change
to hazel editor at the moment I'll leave
it as sandbox deliberately because his
letter does very much in development has
sandbox at least has a like a test
running and will actually fix up sandbox
today as well so that it doesn't have
any of the docs based off and it just
kind of has that that original test that
we had so if we go to if we go to hazel
editor I'm gonna mark that adds this as
the start up project and then I'm gonna
start refactoring a few of these things
so sandbox 2d doesn't exist here it's
called editor layer will have will say
hazel editor which is a the difference
here as well as this well everything
here is gonna be inside the hazel
namespace because it's part of hazel and
that's kind of nice because we don't
need to use this everywhere so hazel
editor is going to push a layer here and
that's going to be I I think I might
want to revisit this stuff in the future
cuz I'm not sure if I still like the way
this is set up but um like you know with
with these things well we'll talk about
that a different day and then this will
return you
editor okay so this is kind of the basic
setup we've just refactored it so that
it's not sandbox but it's you know hazel
editor now this is supposed to push the
editor layer which is called sandbox 2d
so again I'll just rename this to the
editor layer will remove hazel from here
and wrap this in the hazel and name
space alright
and again our goal right now is just to
recreate what we had in the last episode
so we're gonna leave everything intact
we're just changing it to editor layer
and I will also fix up a lot of these
things we're not gonna have this stuff
here realistically I hope that what we
were using by the way I might be fairly
stupid here but I I hope that what we
were using was sandbox 2d and on example
okay good because otherwise I've taken
the wrong layer and it might have been
broken and that would not have been a
good time okay no Hazel's here there's a
few more left I'll get rid of Thor's and
that looks pretty good
let's go to the CPP file we'll change
this to be editor layout we probably
want like we might want a precompiled
header as well in the future but I won't
do that today and then we have so
sandbox 2d I'm just going to find her
place I'm up sturdy to edit Leia in the
current documents all day to do all of
that at once done that's it I think
everything looks like it compiles let's
compile has a letter so make sure
everything compiles and links
successfully well I have some coffee
beautiful let's run it okay a little bit
of a crash probably because of assets
non-existing if I had to guess OpenGL
shader that's also something we should
probably test against things like I'm
missing assets let's grab the sandbox
assets paste them into hazel editor and
we're on that again okay we're all good
and well basically where we were last
time but now this is the hazel editor
and in fact I don't know if there's a
way to rename it from hazel engine to
like something else because I think the
application we do window create and I
think the default window prop says that
it's hazel engine so I think we can if
we how about we do this as well
I think to make this happen to luck
isn't to give it a name we can create a
window with window crops but application
of the moment is was blocking else
because application we don't have an
application name so as a little quick
thing for now we'll say name right
because it's pretty reasonable when
you're creating your application you
should be able to give us a name and
then what this will do all of this will
do really is yeah by default
I won't require a name but what I will
say is that if a name has been given I
don't know if I actually want to have a
different application maybe just hazel
engine or maybe even hazel app can be a
default name I don't like to have too
many defaults going on and unfortunately
we kind of have this default title and
then we have hazel app and it's kind of
all over the place but anyway let's go
back here and then to create that window
props and I know I keep jumping back and
forth and for that I apologize so we
need title let's get rid of these
unsigned ants I don't use that both
typing in Russian accidentally as usual
you end 32t will keep and then and I
keep I really mean change will change
this to you and 32 T's because that's
basically what we use everywhere now not
a big fan of you at unsigned int so
anymore 1280 by 720 and title is hazel
engine and we have a default within
Heinz so technically we can just
probably say we want window props name
that should work okay and now if I run
this again but we go to Hazel editor app
and when we actually make this
application we actually say application
and then we give it a name such as hazel
editor we can now give our application a
name we should also be able to give it
width and height and all that stuff but
like initializing an application and
setting it up isn't is a little bit more
evolved than just like passing in some
integers that are the width in the
height of the app like that's something
that you do if you're just making out a
little bit
sandbox roll test but if you you know if
you've got a whole engine you know you
don't have like a constructor that takes
in a width and a height for your game
that's a bit weird because it's
dependent on a lot of on a lot of things
it's not usually it's not programmed in
you can definitely have like a default
width and height but a lot of that's
dependent on property is a lot of us
depending on how you left at last so in
other words if you used the editor and
then you maximized and then you closed
it you probably expect it to come back
maximized not at the same size every
single time so there's a few things to
consider there as well that's largely it
if we go back to sandbox the other thing
I I said that I wanted to do was
actually just basically get rid of the
docking here and you know revert it to
not be a dock space so if I get rid of
all of this and and is that it oh we
have the frame buffers I'll get rid of
the frame buffer cuz we don't need that
inside sandbox they start at the moment
sandbox is going to become our runtime
test so the idea is we create a game
with hazel editor which will basically
create a whole bunch of game data and
then sandbox is going to be the
application that loads that game
daughter in and also might have a bunch
of other zvp files that dupes and things
if you want to do that and that's gonna
that's gonna be the wrong time so
sandbox is like our game test but hazel
editor is like the actual like it's
action it's an actual hazel tool that
you use to build applications or games
so that's the deal with those two things
I think that's I think that's it yeah
well we won't create frame buffer
obviously let's switch to this project
and run it I just have a little custom
shortcut ctrl shift P it whatever file
you have there it if you hit ctrl shift
P it makes that we still got this it
makes that the sava project okay so once
get rid of that maybe so we have our
check a book texture let's get rid of
that and the big the big like panel is
just it's because we left at lodge last
time okay that's it so we're back about
we've got all our functionality back
now if I go back to his letter to AB
from children to P an f5 then we have
hazel editor and this is like our editor
where we have our dock space
and I think everything is working pretty
well so what we're gonna do next time is
actually talk about getting the ayam GUI
panel to be what we're gonna make a new
I'm giel panel which is going to be our
viewport and that's whatever size that
panel is that's this that's gonna be the
size of this thing we also have to fix
things like scrolling because my scroll
wheel doesn't work right now even those
WASD actually does and I'm not I'm also
it kind of looks flipped to me so I just
realized that because WASD is making
good see if you want to flip it back
what on earth am i doing editor layout
so I'm not sure why exactly is clipped
probably because 0 0 0 like zero on the
y-axis is probably the top and I'm going
where as in you know I've been jealous
at the bottom so I think these UVs are
just a little bit messed up so the way
that we can fix that so we've got UV 0
UV 1 okay 0 & 1 so that's just the min
and Max so what we can do is change this
so that our min instead of being 0 0 is
0 1 and our maths is 1 0 instead of 1 1
and that will basically flip the image
because we're just changing the actual Y
coordinates and this is just canceling
diagnostic session thank you visual
studio I should probably switch to like
vim or something now the whole thing's
not responding come on man just run my
program all right there we go sorry did
that flip it I mean it's kind of hard to
tell isn't it which probably try and
draw something I don't know if I flipped
it or not it should have right because I
did that which we were drawing some what
am i doing you know I didn't flip it
because I mean oh no I'm in the right
thing I'm but I'm in this stupid right
this is the mistake I made last time and
like it was clear that I was stupid for
doing this but anyway whatever okay
there we go now at the image of slips
because W actually makes the camera go
up which is what we expect okay so that
is that now scrolling doesn't work I
imagine that's because the scrolling is
being somehow sucked up by I am going
maybe that Geritol the event is not
being propagated really easy to figure
out if that's the case because if we go
to well if we go to event here this
might be bad though but if I cuz I'm
sure I'm gonna get many events and it
doesn't look like I'm getting any events
in there delay which is very strange so
all the mouse events are not happening
in editor layer for some reason that's
odd that's something that we need to
investigate next time so in summary next
time what we're going to do is we're
going to continue on with the whole dock
space adventure obviously and we're
going to basically take the I'm goanna
we're gonna make a viewport one and
we're gonna make that display our frame
buffer for our scene and that way we're
going to be able to have like adorable
environment with panels everywhere and a
viewport in the middle that you can drag
off put into another monitor dock it
wherever you want and do what you would
expect with a level editor so I hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please don't forget to hit the like
button and help support this series and
my channel on patreon.com for such the
channel huge thank you to all the people
supporting this don't forget that if you
do become a patron you'll get access to
weekly live streams from me developing
hazel dev and all of the fun 3d stuff
and like the editor workflows and
basically stuff that eventually makes
its way into this series here as well as
access to that source code and like
other exclusive content thank you guys
for watching I will see you next time
goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]